I I want to start with you
um
how has this journey been for you
um you you went straight from clemency
to till
and
um light Fair light you know light
afternoon watching no it's like these
films uh they're two very they're
focused movies that tackle very specific
issues that also resonate profoundly
today
you jump from clemency to tell how was
that for you and kind of how did you get
into a mindset to prepare you to go on
this journey with these fine people
well
yeah I was with these fine people to
help with the journey
um I was reluctant
um you know when the producers reached
out to me it was a month or two after my
last film clemency premiered at Sundance
and I just was not emotionally ready not
only because of the subject matters of
clemency but I I dedicated five and a
half years of my life
it like committed am I like relocated
everything
um taught in prisons just really focused
on that and that was draining and also
my life really changed after clemency
and so I was also trying to process that
and so it took I took time before
responding to Barbara Brockley who is
another producer on the film and it that
first you know Barbara has a persistent
way about her
and she was persistent and all the
producers I met with all of them in New
York yeah in New York and
um
what was they asked me if I can share
what would my my point of view would be
you know what would my what what Vision
I had for it and
I they were just so
committed to my artistic View and my
artistic ability that they really they
told me they'll give me the space for a
creative autonomy you know and as an
artist that was just really incredible
but I it took me about a year and a half
before I was really fully ready to dive
into the making of the film before that
I had gone I had started doing research
and catching up on a lot of the research
that Keith had done and went to
Mississippi a few times
um but uh it the emotional recalibration
was therapy meditation it was
just lightness so just hanging out with
my sister friends drinking wine
um crying as well and not out of sadness
but just release and um and really
questioning Within Myself am I ready to
do this and to be honest like the the me
getting the space to be able to make
this film tell this story so solely
focused on Mimi's perspective and the
love that was between her and Emmett and
to be able to balance the film with
moments of joy and community and love
really helped in in
um the making of the film it helped
alleviate some of the emotional tension
I was feeling Within Myself
and Keith Your Story Goes even further
back with this relationship with this
film and a lot of research came from
your documentary the untold story of of
Emmett Lewis Hill
um so like when that you know from the
beginnings of this to now from the seed
that was planted to now how have you
seen this this project evolve
well this project evolved tremendously
um
I um wow
it's taken me 29 years to get here
um this is something that Emmett Till's
mother my mentor for eight and a half
years wanted to see diamond
and so early on in my life I was
introduced to him until at the age of
10. and so it was when I saw that
photograph and Jet Magazine I was in my
parents study and I discovered the
photograph and that story became a
cautionary tale for me for the my entire
teenage year
but it wasn't until I actually had my
own major run-in with racism and that
was when I was assaulted by undercover
police officer for dancing with a white
class men of mine where my journey
actually begun
um and fighting the Injustice that we
see in our everyday lives and so the
impetus for me in this journey came from
mother Mobley herself it was her
inspiration
um that she instilled in me at an early
age that actually brought me on this
journey to continue
um to uphold her Legacy as well as to
continue to fight for them for the
justice for him until himself and so the
project that we've just produced
um was you know in 67 years
no one has been able to make this film
mother Mobley herself had two film deals
in 1955 and 56 but no one would touch
the story
and so it's truly remarkable to be here
this evening you know knowing that we
were able to achieve
um what many could not which is to
finally tell this story to the masses
yes yes
um
so to our two heroes in the center
Danielle and uh JJ yes
um as the two characters front and
center
um in this movie
um I'm sure how did you even begin
to I I wouldn't even imagine how you
begin to approach this but also how did
you mindfully take care of this
narrative and also take care of each
other you know and at the same time
creating this like mother-son Bond like
I feel like it's a lot that's like four
or five questions in one I know there's
what is wrong with you it's a foreign
which question are we starting with
let's dive into
um how did we begin to prepare oh the
accents yeah
you already said
oh goodness I mean it's a community
effort right for me from the beginning
um uh working with genoya has been the
most uh focused rigorous uh hyper
disciplined effort that I've ever done
she was right with me at every step
um we we established that when we did
the director session you know I I work
with people who I trust and who I feel I
can be led and led by and walked beside
and that's what she she did for uh for
me for everybody for the cast and the
crew
um
they just start I started with the the
book with death of Innocence um written
by Mamie uh with Christopher Benson and
I utilized that as a Bible because it is
her words it describes so many of the
scenes that we witness uh in the film
and then we had a wealth of archival
footage and our archival photos of
Chicago 1955 of Mississippi 1955 of
Sumner of Mound Bayou of every
historical figure in the film
uh and and and just digging into every
crevice of the script uh how do you
prepare therapeutically or or like care
wise yeah
y'all were together a lot and how did
you just create that Bond and you know
learn to trust yeah see it doesn't begin
with me it begins with Jalen okay and I
would do you want me to do it here I'll
do it because I'll be doing it
um Jalen's audition Chem test with me
was lovely I taught him to sing uh to
get the rhythm of he beeped when he
should have bopped by Dizzy Gillespie
and then towards the end of that session
Jalen says Miss Daniel I just want to
tell you I think you have a beautiful
smile
and I said
talking to
you know like how
encourage that kind of style and
Charisma and you know joy and like we
just laugh it's always been that with
with me and him and and that that was
you know reflective of image you know
that kind of um Joy uh that inherent joy
and uh we just I just take care of him
and love him in that way you know
you want to add how has how has the
experience
yeah yeah the experience for me has
um
it's been amazing like you know with
with having you know such heavy material
it's it's important to have a support
group of people who can uplift you while
simultaneously uplifting them
um and going into this you know
it's my mom my mom is my therapist
you're here come on Mom right over there
so it was it was you know getting in
that mindset and and her as well because
you know her having to view her son this
way knowing knowing that I'm gonna be
okay but it's you know a mother feels
differently
um
so it was us communicating and making
sure we're both ready
um for this and when we got into it uh
you know my mom she'll she'll let you
know straight off the badge you feel
about somebody right and and she let me
know and she knew herself just how
greatly that she felt about Danielle and
knew that I was in very good hands while
filming
um so we didn't actually spend a lot of
time together before filming oh wow but
that that brought us closer because
every day the bond just grew
um and and has been growing you know
since then so yeah if I might also add
the day he learned they got the part
like okay so you can time me Dave he got
the part it was a meeting and they
didn't realize that they didn't know
right and so we didn't have the script
in hand he was ready to do he was ready
to do audition again right right and so
it's myself to know you Jalen his mother
EMA and Barbara broccoli were sitting in
the this big table and we're talking and
and then at one moment he goes
y'all talking to me like like I got it
yeah and then you know your ghost
you want me to do your my um
would you like to be our image
that's a great impression
[Laughter]
and Jamie just jumps up his mother is
crying and he kind of you did you cry
did you get emotional nonetheless he
came around the table he picks me up he
spins me around and like he's playing
the music and you know it just I did you
get weepy I thought Barbara got weepy I
got a weepy it was just
a beautiful moment to to to to to feel
that for him and to feel that we are all
hyper connected in that in that uh in
the effort that we will be going on
um I think we're out of time
unfortunately
um but um I could talk to you all about
this forever the conversation will
continue I'm sure but um thank you all
so much thank you chanoia uh Danielle
Jalen and Keith
um and please tell people to watch this
so we could have the conversation you
know uh and thank you all for coming out
tonight really eaters everywhere it is
people people's minds are changed when
they talk to people who have seen this
movie yes so tell people that you saw
this movie and how it made you feel when
you came out and hopefully it is the
feeling of inspiration not a movie it's
a moment
tell the kids too yes the kids please do
thank you all so much so much